dust yourself off we have a brand
spanking new episode of Monarch which
means tons of new theories and events to
discuss and yes I have a juicy new
theory that hence KO is alive and how
she'll be back there's also this
midseason trailer that has all new
footage on where the show is headed I'll
have a whole breakdown of that at the
end of the video and if you haven't seen
the trailer yet I've left a link to that
in the description as always there are
time stamps to all the topics I'll be
covering and before we begin make sure
to like And subscribe every little bit
helps one of the biggest Mysteries
leading into this episode is where the
hell is Godzilla you can't tell me that
a giant monster the size of a skyscraper
just up and vanished if I were to Hazard
a guess Godzilla has entered these
series of interconnected tunnels and
caves that we saw in Godzilla versus
Kong this is what he's using to get
around undetected it's also possible
since Algeria is right next to the
Mediterranean Sea that Godzilla made it
into the ocean where it would be more
difficult to detect him the main focus
of this episode is m 's past right off
the bat May is kidnapped by a company
called AET or applied experimental
Technologies and it's not your typical
bag over thehead kidnapping she gets her
own private jet and isn't even tied up
30 months ago or 2 years and 6 months
May was hired as a programmer for AET by
this woman Brenda Holland this work was
appealing to me because this company
sought to change the world with its
neurolink technology Tech that could
help people walk again among other
things this is eerily similar to Elon
Musk neuralink technology but 6 months
into the job she finds that she's been
relegated to menial tasks and feels her
talents are being squandered so she does
some digging and hacks into some secret
files which leads her to the cybernetic
neuro interface unit a restricted area
where she uncovers that AET has been
performing tests on animals so she
basically goes scorched Earth and
deletes years and millions of dollars
worth of research prompting her to
assume a new identity and fly to Japan
now may or or Kora Mato if you're to use
her real name must face the music being
brought back to Brenda and AET Brenda
has a deal for me she knows May is in
with these guys searching for Godzilla
and these mudos might be the next big
thing for the company imagine the tech
they could make if they could study
these giant creatures so in exchange for
info may can get her life back if not
A's lawyers will clamp down on her we
never see if May agrees to these terms
just that Brenda leaves the office
saying she's glad they could come to an
agreement but where it gets weird is
that may tells Kate and the others that
she can't be that person anymore that
spy she can't go with them so it appears
May is not going to take A's deal but
what brings May back with the team is a
deal Verdugo makes with Kate if Verdugo
can get May to come along with him Kate
will get her Lee Shaw so some backdoor
deal happens between Monarch and AET
that freeze May allowing her to
reconnect with a team just what this
deal is remains to be scene but it might
have something to do with Walter Simmons
and Apex cybernetics May briefly refers
to someone named Walter having enough
money to recoup A's losses from her hack
and in Brenda's final scene she talks to
a man she refers to as Mr Simmons as the
Apex cybernetic logo appears on her
computer these are both references to
Walter Simmons who you may remember from
Godzilla versus Kong he is the CEO of
Apex cybernetics at tech company
hellbent on killing Godzilla and
creating Mecha Titans that be piloted
telepathically a and its neuralink look
to be the precursor to this Tech with
the resources of Duval's Rogue Monarch
unit Lee and Duval are able to take over
Monarch Outpost 88 in Alaska this
appears to be the same Outpost Lee and
the others encountered in episode 4 the
one near this glowing Rift now there are
some interesting bits of information
here Lee tells the workers that they're
either with him on the right side of
history or prepare for Humanity to be on
the endangered species list now this
doesn't necess necessarily mean he wants
to kill Godzilla in fact last episode he
said he wanted to protect him so it
appears Lee wants to stop the other
Titans and sees them as a threat we know
these Titans appear to be attracted to
these glowing riffs and Lee has found a
way to stop them before detonating these
explosives he says now watch this almost
as if he knows what's about to happen
and I don't think anyone could have
predicted how this explosion was going
to defy physics so does this mean Lee
has done this before there's a lot about
Le past that we simply don't know like
that failed Mission ver Dugo talked
about a few episodes ago now as we move
into our trailer slothing section we
might have some answers now there are
only three episodes left but a new
mid-season trailer came out which offers
insight into where the show is headed so
I'll be covering that as well we have
this shot of a man and woman touching
hands last episode we learned about Lee
and koo's Affair so maybe this is them
or perhaps this is Bill Randa and KO
we'll see him wear a white shirt and
similar tie in this shot however we
can't see a bandage on his left hand
speaking of this shot this has got to be
young Hiroshi or else why would Bill be
kissing a random boy on the head this is
the shot I'm most interested in Lee and
a team preparing for some sort of
mission it has a kind of astronaut Vibe
but I'm thinking instead of these guys
going into space they're going into the
hollow Earth in this round metal ball
we'll see a similar if not the same
metal ball years later with May and Kate
in front of it here's Lee in front of a
laptop that says primed the same Prime
that showed up before closing the rift
in Alaska could he be trying to close
another Rift remember there remain two
additional locations that Hiroshi was
looking into that we haven't visited yet
one in Central Asia the other in Vietnam
or Cambodia so either Lee is still in
Alaska here or we've moved on to another
one of these locations across from him
is Kate who looks a bit concerned she'll
probably tell him to stop what he's
doing to which we'll get more
information on what exactly his
motivations are we know that the team
makes its way to a monarch headquarters
in Virginia with Tim we can see Verdugo
here telling them that these Titans are
an inescapable reality this electronic
map here looks to be at Monarch pointing
out specific areas which have high
levels of gamma radiation there's one to
the left here in Mexico which may hint
at Rodan who we saw in 2019s Godzilla
king of the monsters the Algeria reading
where Godzilla was found here is in the
center remember how Tim and Hoshi had
Central Asia and Vietnam Cambodia on his
map well here's the Central Asian
location in Kazakhstan the same place
Koo was lost in 1959 the other location
is Myanmar just a bit off from this
Vietnam and Cambodia location here's
Kate in some sort of facility as armed
soldiers take over perhaps Lee and
Duval's Rogue Monarch group this is the
ion Dragon the same one found near the
USS Len in the Philippines back in 52
I'm going to go out on a limb here and
say this is Lee and may escaping some
sort of gamma reaction the purple and
blue colors look a lot like those found
in Alaska now this shot is super
interesting this looks to be the inside
of one of those metal balls that Lee
went into way back when either they are
time traveling or heading into the
hollow Earth but what I'm really curious
about is this mystery person with long
straight black hair we see the back of
their head here and inside the metal
ball here the only other person who fits
this description is KO who we last Saw
falling into the same Kazakhstan
location back in 1959 am I crazy to
believe that she comes back well
remember in episode 2 how KO and Bill
found these bodies in the USS laen who
had been there for over a decade and
they remark how it looks like their
bodies hadn't age due to being covered
in this goo we never saw KO die so it's
possible her body was taken by these
creatures and put into a similar
cryostasis here is Bill getting blown
away after that mission Lee Was
preparing for explodes similar to that
of the rift in Alaska that explains how
Lee knew what was going to happen when
these explosives went off we are back in
C has EX stand to see Kate fighting off
one of these grown-up egg creatures I'm
not sure whether this takes place before
or after she gets into this metal ball
and she's also wearing the same shirt
we'll see her in this shot with the ball
in the background this all seems to be
culminating in a final battle between
Godzilla and the ion Dragon the place
where this takes place looks a bit weird
perhaps it's in between the hollow Earth
and surface as we can see multiple of
these riffs all over the place wherever
it is I'm looking forward to this
showdown and now I turn it over to you
what are your thoughts and theories for
the upcoming episodes let me know in the
comments below thanks for watching be
sure to like And subscribe and for more
bad takes you can follow me on Twitter
and Instagram at thinkstory YT until
next time remember Daddy loves you very
much